but the first thing we got to talk about
is Joe Biden pardoning can we play the
clip for people who haven't heard it we
are gonna play the clip oh my goodness
please we are going to play the clip let
me it's kind of gross
yes fair warning it's a juicy gross part
no the swallow well one the smaller one
was no that was like force he forced
that out that was like a trump that was
forceful like a trumpet yeah I'd romp
Wow
Biden yeah buddy I'm gonna do it you
ready to do it ready buy it no I'm gonna
put it by the yeah yeah you guys ready
yeah okay so here's the story there was
a pretty loud fart noise during a Joe
Biden livestream from BuzzFeed
politicians they say can be full of hot
air
Oh BuzzFeed just admit it it was a fart
and you all know it deep down inside of
you you know it and you note it was Joe
Biden watch this clip you know I have to
cut those teachers and firefighters
police officers and cut critical health
care programs or stop work on roads and
bridges so what does the human cost of
lack of state local fiscal relief from a
Boston or stop work on roads and bridges
so that is what a busy humans are cheeks
slapping right there BuzzFeed BuzzFeed
even mentions that this dude is like oh
yeah yeah shot look at this face did she
just he's like what what taking it back
you know he's trying he's a professional
that's being professional that that's
all that happens is just little eyebrow
raise a little good you know check
yourself a little bit I'm good I'm good
I'm listening to what you're saying sir
sure I can't believe it I'm not
distracted yeah what oh man
someone said it was a shart that's what
I was thinking I'm like whoever it is
needs to change their pants cuz that was
wet and juicy you'd come on y'all know
it and you know I love how they're
always lying right wing figures pounce
there are conservative pounce on Joe
Biden's fight stop at BuzzFeed like it
right-wing figures on Twitter soon clip
the moment and and it was subsequently
shared by the conservative outlet The
Daily Caller as well as Trump jr. why
are you telling me this yeah no speak
you're sharing the story how about we
drop the fruit article about it
goodness so I voted I voted that look at
this so what do you think I love I love
that so the first one of the most votes
is made by Biden 57% I admit I had voted
I voted for that one I would have to
yeah but they voted by I don't care I'm
just glad you put resources into this
important story for the record like for
the record I want to I want this on
record this is the only time I will have
ever voted for Biden just making that
not really a fart but some other noise a
lot of people believe that really I
think it's possible by no way I
definitely heard cheek slapping farts
the shart heard round the world
yeah I don't even want to think about
like okay all right here we go you ready
for this in order to determine whether
or not that truly was a fart you have to
think about the physiology of Joe Biden
yeah and you know I don't want to just
an old guy okay these things happen yes
this is why I think RIT I think it was
real because he's an old guy and that
was like yes man fart that was such an
old man fart butt buzz yeah and the case
and he didn't even he didn't stop
talking he just rolled right through it
that's an old man thing to do but he
like right but he does like [ __ ] he felt
it yeah well they move forward and then
came back on the on the return as it
came out and Tom wolf was like what did
I just experience I go do you guys think
he's hard of hearing Joe Biden yeah I
totally do probably yeah he probably
didn't think anyone he'd hear it he's
like I feel it
nobody hears it right do you think he
even heard it do you think he even knows
that he farted yeah people are like man
how did you fart and he's like me he
said up cuz he felt what but yeah I
don't think yeah who knows he did lean
forward a little bit and lean which I
check this out yeah check us out
it's not the first time there's been a
strange fart now this story man look
we're going there cuz we won't we go to
dark and dangerous places he on Tim cast
IRL
I couldn't hold my laugh back so Adam
didn't know about this story Erik's well
well as a Democrat from California and
BuzzFeed did an investigation even vice
did an investigation where vices like
you know who farted an investigation and
like but to be out to be fair like it
really did bring everyone together it's
true but no one believed this guy check
us out a lawmaker denied ripping an
absolutely enormous fart on live
television quote it was not me
Rep Eric's well well said in a text
message it's funny though fart gait
trended on Twitter well any funny I
wasn't me though you know and and
because of SpaceX and John boyega and
also other stuff going on I think we're
not gonna get a fart Gate 2 on Twitter
it's kind of sad of all the games of all
the games come on well how many of you
would like to hear Eric's well well fart
can we do it would you like to hear
people I definitely would love to hear
it again
it made me crack up it's so funny and
the look on his face can we get a full
screen on this he totally did it full
screen yeah oh my goodness ok you ready
you ready enjoy this sound on let's hope
it works taxpayer dollars to ask the
Ukrainians to help them cheat an
election help them cheap we're held on
election and play again we're playing
again that's akshay every quiet
everybody here we go
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help them cheat an election ok no no
hold on hold on this dude it's so good
oh man this dude ok listen he stops
talking he paused and he clearly
clenches up yeah any Glenn Zack and you
were they claimed they tried saying that
it was like at the same exact moment
that he paused and clenched somebody in
the studio dragged a mug across a table
nope who drags mugs actually we'll say
that in the BuzzFeed article do they say
let me see if I can really important
here we go here it is like yep the show
later tried to explain the sound on
Twitter saying it was all um a mug
scraping across a desk prove it prove it
show me the video of someone scraping a
mug across that makes that sound if it
was there and yeah I
proof yep this receipt they're just
trying to practicality done Kevin oh
that's freaking hilarious I don't know
man what would you do like if you were
on camera and you're talking and you
were like this is a very important story
and what would you do
I already told you about it I dude I own
my farts for a own most use I do it's
like what else what other choice do you
have
you know what yeah no it's me of like a
[ __ ] this imports me of it reminds
me of a very important philosophy always
tell people oh boy you only embarrass
yourself yes you it's like embarrassment
is an internal thing so the way the way
I explain is with farts so I look at it
this way if you're in an elevator and
people are round and you're like oh man
you fart and then you're all embarrassed
because everyone's like oh god you're
like oh jeez they know it was me
that's embarrassments your fault yeah
cuz if you're in an elevator and you're
like hey dude
so wait make eye contact
oh yeah hey about it and shuffle it
towards them no but I was thinking about
this like in schools because I was like
watching a show or something where like
some kid to class farted mm-hmm and then
got all embarrassed everyone laughed at
him they were like I you farted and I'm
like but what if the person went like
this he farted and they start Fanning at
somebody they would go oh god that
person laughs right mm-hmm you choose to
be the butt of the joke right you to say
you're like oh I'm so embarrassed if I
start laughing go buy a you you're the
ones who got to smell it you know most
people don't mind the smell of their own
I'd be like I bet why you laughing dude
you're sniffing my poop it's in your
nose dude you know it is kind of random
people are saying soy farts but when I
went when I went vegan my fart stopped
smelling like yo my my gas was bad ask
anyone that know me previant
now it's like now it's just hot air
something happened where you
accidentally had a piece of cheese like
yes that's right there was I don't
remember what it was in write it was
something no and I had there was like
there was cheese in it and I think it
was like the crust of a pizza or
something yeah I don't remember what
our personal fart gate yeah and then
sudden it was like you smelled it you
fumigated the house hey hey Tim I don't
know if you know this I fart around you
all the time know it you know to get
serious about like Eric's while denying
it I don't know if Joe Biden denied it
but think about how they deny it it
actually just makes everything worse
like yeah yeah why deny nothing happened
you clearly farted dude come on did yes
now you're just lying do we need to play
the video again but what it's it's it's
a tough spot I guess like but you gotta
just own it you know you gotta you gotta
laugh and be like you know what I got to
be honest I didn't know Mike that Mike
would pick that up how could I hope it
made you all laugh yeah you're making
people laugh who can what's wrong with
that you know he could've done fartings
funny you know you know he could have
done mm-hmm if he did an appearance like
after this and they asked him about it
and he said let me tell you guys some
everybody farts yeah I didn't think the
mic would pick it up but I'm glad it
made you all let's see here's the thing
though his fart was funny yes you know
what there are some people that are like
oh did I miss the fire this is for the
people who missed the part listen to how
sad this is if I could put this in slow
mode for you I would you know I have to
cut those teachers and firefighters
police officers and cut critical health
care programs or stop work on roads and
bridges so what does the human cost of
lack of state and local fiscal go back
to the beginning
it looks like he's leaning forward like
trying to get he's like oh man
it's there I got a lien for it a little
bit oh it's coming out all right I can
lean back now no it's like he leans back
as it comes out right cuz he knows it's
coming
he's like I go more like he wrote it he
released the pressure
look at Tom now Tom Wolf's face it's
just
police officers and cut critical health
care programs or stop work on roads and
bridges so what does the human cost
yeah yeah he knows it
yeah you heard it it was like that I
just okay I did just hear that I I did
he was very professional I mean this is
the hard-hitting news you will find the
Tim cast-iron don't do this that often
it's long we don't let a fart go
uninvestigated unlike what BuzzFeed is
on the trip on the trail okay yeah so uh
the investigation with Sue's we I think
I think we've sufficiently no beat the
fart we're beating a dead fart so why
don't we while we move on though to to
the actual I gotta say though there's
some people in the comments doing a new
hashtag shark gate I think that's way
way more accurate I'm sorry you gotta
you gotta go back to go back to this
play on this here we go
look at Joe Biden right here just look
at this screen you know what you know
what he's thinking right there what oh
no it's wet well we go back go back look
look that is that is the look of a man
who just realized he's charged misjudged
it yep trusted it that's it son of a gun
mm-hmm man oh man that that might have
gotten into the chair oh my goodness
that this is this is true journalism
everyone we are uniting the populous
left and right goodness yeah I tell you
we will all be holding hands in
Washington DC in front of the White
House rocking back and forth singing
songs because Joe Joe's Biden's fart has
unified us
wonderful there's gonna be like a beaut
it's beautiful gonna be a dude with like
a Gadsden flag and like a Trump shirt
and there's gonna be an anti foot guy
with like a lookout Barney shirt and
they're gonna be screaming and then
someone's gonna rap to him and be like
guys Joe Biden farted and they're gonna
look at each other and they're gonna hug
yeah
yeah the world
it's beautiful world peace thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you